the 90s was a decade full of awesome
animated series but perhaps the thing
that are stuck most with us from this
time period are the hero's iconic
animated figures from who battle evil in
one form or another and inspire us to
better face the problems that confront
us in our own lives if you're watching
this we're going to go ahead and assume
that you know who Batman is what you
might not know however is that Batman
the Animated Series is quite possibly
the best version of the character to
ever exist a perfect synthesis of over
50 years of comics that were distilled
into bold animation and subtle
sophisticated stories almost every
version of Batman is super cool and
intimidating in their superhero persona
but what makes this version of the
character surprisingly refreshing is
that bare with us here he's actually a
well adjusted guy unlike in some
portrayals of the dark knights who treat
their Bruce Wayne persona as an
afterthought this Batman understands the
importance of work-life balance the
animated Bruce Wayne is genuinely kind
and connected to those around him a
proper father figure to Robin who's not
afraid to show a fraction to a surrogate
son and the philanthropist - this is
much good for Gotham during the day your
se does at night we come back here have
Christmas dinner and watch It's a
Wonderful Life
you know I've never seen that I could
never get past the title you might think
that this more hopeful tone would take
some of the punch out of these stories
but if anything it often makes some hit
even harder increasing the dichotomy
between Batman's two separate lives for
instance when you start off by
establishing that Bruce Wayne and Harvey
Dent are actually genuine friends who
knew each other before things went bad
it makes Harvey's inevitable
transformation into the villainous
two-faced even more tragic the darkness
is even darker when you contrast it with
the lights so for our money the animated
series Batman is as good as the Dark
Knight gets Spacey gluttonous clumsy and
not the bright Sun the typical traits a
most people would associate with a
superhero lets alone the leader of an
entire team of reincarnated soldiers
with an inescapable destiny to stand
against evil forces across time and
space that is however a description that
fits usagi tsukino perfectly which is
why she assumed there had been some sort
of mistake when a talking cat showed up
to tell her she was a reincarnation of a
magical superhero princess
from the moon I was told that Sailor
Moon is clumsy stupid lazy and unrefined
and there's no way a girl like that
could ever pass the princess seminar it
kind of makes sense she wasn't alone
either
the rest of her new superhero team were
also pretty shocked especially the fiery
Rey he know he felt like she herself was
far more suited to the job of Team
Leader however sign when Sun woo soggy
in a super heroic identity of Sailor
Moon proved to the rest of her team and
to herself that she could rise to any
occasion fueled by a deep burning love
for her friends that's what makes the
story of Sailor Moon so compelling in a
world full of perfect Superman is
refreshing to see someone for whom being
a superhero doesn't come easily someone
who thinks of herself as a failure
someone who would rather just stay in
bed all day and eat snacks
after all if everyone thought that
Sailor Moon wasn't capable of saving the
world only for her to step up and do it
anyway maybe the rest of us can find a
similar reserve of strength buried deep
within ourselves
if whose sake can be Sailor Moon we can
all rise to the occasion and our own
stories too although she started off as
a side character on Beavis and Butthead
the misanthropic perspective team daria
morgendorffer got her own spin-off in
1997 by the end of the decade she had
grown into a pop-culture sensation in
her own right just as famous as a two
buffoonish former co-stars her solo
series simply called daria tells the
story of her family moving away from the
DIMM duo and into the fictional town of
Lawndale where she attempts to
assimilate into a new high school
populated by a faster array of foolish
teenagers and even more foolish adults
because of Darius and ability to hold
her tongue in the face of the fakery
that surrounds her the show's five
seasons see her and her best friend Jane
clashing with pretty much every single
institution social structure and
cultural norm that exists in highschool
life well my history teacher hates me
because I know the answers but there are
some interesting idiots in my class
that's great if you haven't watched
Daria before you're probably at least
familiar with the basics of a character
a gothy emotionless somewhat smug
sourpuss who hates everyone if you think
that's all there is to the character
though we urge you to give it a watch
and discover just how much death a new
answer character and the series have to
offer there its roots as a BB
and bud said spin-off means that her
show is never fully able to divorce
itself from the trend of lowbrow
nineties humor in which it was created
the show can be transcendent at times
with incredible and affecting character
work mixed in with the comedy Dario's
philosophical monologuing it's every bit
as beautifully tragic as the characters
who racked up critical acclaim on
prestige dramas ten years later not all
cartoons from the 90s of aged well
especially in light of the animation
Renaissance of the 21st century but
somehow with each passing year that sig
just seems to be getting better in part
this is due to its hilarious and
enigmatic lead that tick himself we
never get much backstory on exactly who
the tick is under his mask or if it even
is a mask but there are three things
about sin that we can say with certainty
he dresses like a blue bug he's not
invulnerable and he's completely
clueless but despite all this he has a
good heart and he does his best to fight
the good fight and stand as a role model
for his anxious sidekick Arthur the tick
is such an appealing character that even
though his animated series was canceled
after an all-too-brief
36 episode run he's come back in
live-action twice and cemented himself
as a cult favorite after all these years
something about the texture resonates
with us even if we can't exactly
articulate why maybe it's a unique
combination of a selfless nature the
vast and earned confidence that comes
along with his unstoppable powers and
his penchant for spouting nonsensical
aphorisms maybe it's the fact that as
superheroes have become the most popular
things in the movie theatres the tics
sharp genre parody just gets more
relevant to pop culture maybe it's that
we all feel like Arthur from time to
time and wish we had someone like the
tick in our lives to remind us of a
simple truth even if you had no idea
what's going on you can still save the
day if only we could all have the
confidence compassion and zest for life
of the tick one of the roles of a
superhero is to inspire people and there
are few cartoon characters who inspired
young audiences during the 90s quite
like Miss Frizzle from the Magic School
Bus
play to perfection by Lily Tomlin
Valerie Frizzle is a fourth grade
science teacher no vote jovial attitude
adventurous spirits and colorful
wardrobe whenever she wants to teach her
students a lesson Frizzle takes someone
a reality building field trip around the
titular shape changing bus across four
seasons her class goes pretty much
everywhere from the farthest reaches of
the solar system to the Amazon rain
forests and even into the human body
twice and yes it was just as gross as
every kid wanted it to be with the kids
getting really panicked about where
their classmates digestive system was
going to take them before they
remembered that burping exists and they
could leave the way they came aside from
the gross-out factor there's so much to
love about miss Frizzle she's fearless
encouraging and she always helps guide
her students to discovering the
solutions to problems on their own
rather than given them all the answers
encouraging them to learn by doing
rather than just lecturing them about
the facts the phrase is the teacher we
all wish we had and it's not just
because she has inexplicable magic
powers although if you want to go deep
down the well of trying to figure out
exactly what is going on with miss
Frizzle and her strange abilities that's
a fairly popular theory among Doctor Who
fans at miss Frizzle is a Time Lord and
her school bus is a TARDIS the moody
action fantasy series gargoyles launched
as disney's take on the darker more
sophisticated storytelling style that's
made Batman the Animated Series such a
hits was sadly never as popular as the
Dark Knight revisiting it these days
however shows that it stands the test of
time better than most of its 90s cartoon
contemporaries the aesthetics are sharp
the world-building is deep and the work
put into the characters is truly
impressive by the standards of any
decade pretty much every member of the
principal cast is rock solid
some of them literally but today we're
going to talk about the dark and
tortured heart of the show Goliath the
why is an honourable leader of the
Manhattan clan Goliath is a winged stone
warrior who was cursed to sleep for a
thousand years along with the rest of
his clan before awakening in the modern
world they were in paralleled in battle
Goliath's big heart also means that he
tends to trust people whenever he can
afford to and even sometimes when he
can't versus some of the more cynical
denizens of our modern age such as the
amoral businessman David Santos are
often able to take advantage of this big
lungs good nature as the story
progresses Goliath becomes an
increasingly angry car
but those who think that he's some sort
of violent brute misunderstand him
goliath rage also comes from his tragic
idealism his disappointment that yet
another person who seemed to be his
friend ended up being just another
well-spoken liar it's not often that you
get to describe a cartoon character as
Byronic but goliath certainly fits the
bill between the enduring the soldier
for the classic toy line and cartoon and
the film franchise i hit theaters in
2006 the robots in disguise of
transformers have moved from the fringes
of their culture firmly into the
mainstream even though everyone knows
who megatron is these days though the
focus for all those well publicized funs
memories have always been on the
original 1980s cartoon and not any of
the later iterations of the franchise
and as much as we like the show that's a
shame transformers beast wars are
computer animated 90s series - the
hand-drawn original is worthy of just as
much attention even if it's look some
more than little bit dated like their g1
predecessors Beast Wars sells a story of
two rival factions of robots the
maximals and the Predacons who crash
land on an uncharted planet in classic
Transformers fashion these two warring
teams continue their fighting after
taking on the appearance of the locals
but this time they opted for animals
instead of machines a leader of the
maximals Optimus Primal becomes a
gorilla a disguise which fits his
personality well as he strong
intelligent and imposing in his heart
though a primal is a peaceful troubled
soul he does his best to live up to the
legacy of Optimus Prime the legendary
Autobot from whom he inherited his name
but he always feels destined to live in
the shadow of the greatest Autobot who
ever lived
however primal eventually becomes just
as much of a legend in his own rights
whereas his predecessor was idealistic
and traditional primal realizes the
benefits of being practical and creative
and then to be mentioned that he has a
flying surfboard and a jetpack yeah he's
a robot gorilla with a jetpack that's
the kind of thing that sticks with you
no matter how is animated clearly
Optimus Primal deserves to be remembered
as the icon he is right alongside
everyone's favorite shrug dad check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite animated shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]